[Music]
what are some of the most interesting
attempts at anything related to network
state that
you could mention and the reason i bring
it up is for a while i remember in
silicon valley
there's a lot of talk of seasteading
seasteading seasteading seasteading and
people can look this up and certainly
there are experiments being run and have
been run for a long time with
intentional communities that have
on some level
let's just call them tenets of a
doctrine right or agreements or
commandments
so where would you point what are what
are some interesting things that you're
seeing
that you think are worth mentioning
one important
thing i just want to say is that in the
book i make a distinction i talk about
startup societies and network states and
i define a network state as actually one
that has
diplomatic recognition
from an existing sovereign
which is an unusual definition because
you might say wait a second
like
why does why do you care whether
florida or
you know denmark or the united nations
recognizes you
why should that matter you should be
able to just do it totally from scratch
right
and the the reason that i have that
that's that's a very high bar for
diplomatic recognition the analogy would
be bitcoin starting as a pure internet
phenomenon and then eventually
getting listed on bloomberg and
eventually eventually becoming the
sovereign currency of el salvador right
it attained diplomatic recognition but
it took like 10 years right
the reason is that that as i can get
into diplomatic recognition is actually
very important because it means the
existing it's almost like a the crypto
fiat exchange okay
like you know the exchange between
crypto and fiat the ability to be
halfway
dollars or 95 dollars and five percent
crypto that exchange turns out to be
like a critical part of the entire
transition to crypto in the same way the
exchange or the interface between crypto
countries and fiat countries is the
diplomatic recognition of a network
okay
so that portability is you know one one
dimension of it
another dimension is the one you're
talking about which is physical
migration
and
the thing is that
there's like several things i can say so
first is if somebody plans poorly you
can't be their keeper you know you can't
necessarily look out for them on
everything what you can do is you can
try to reduce the cost or the barriers
to exit
and one of the things i mentioned when i
talked about earlier i said american
anarchy on the other side of the world
what's burgeoning is the opposite of
that which i call chinese control
and the scenario that i think might
happen in china
is there's this book by roger garside
called china coo
and you know various guys george soros
is kind of hinted at this
you know there's this group the cyborg
group in the us that put out a video
about a month ago that's talking about
cyborg has like photos of china and how
they're doing cyborg in china do you see
this video this ghost video
no but i would love a link we'll put it
in the show notes as well
so short answer is or short version is
i think it is possible
i can't say 100
but that
some kind of china coup will be
attempted against
xi jinping or the chinese communist
party
but i don't think it's going to so
whether it's like actually u.s backed or
not i don't know but for garcia to put
out a book like this for soros to make
the comments he's has for this jsoc to
put that video out there for all the
talk about oh they're you know not a
democracy and and you know so on and
like a lot of the
same energy versus russia
it's quite possible that some kind of
china coup will be attempted
i don't think it's going to succeed for
a variety of reasons but that's like the
the thing that the chinese system is
armored against
and i think that the response to an
attempt like that
would be an ai
okay the aii of the chinese state
ripping out
any piece of civil society
by the roots that possibly collaborated
with that
okay and the kinds of consequences of
that i couldn't imagine but it'd be like
they could do cutoffs of physical goods
as targeted reverse physical sanctions
you know like okay we'll sell you chairs
but not these key screws that you need
for certain military things like it
would be viewed as this insanely hostile
act and you might say
well i mean the us government is smart
enough that it won't try that the
establishment try that like
have you noticed nuclear brinkmanship
with russia have we have we seen you
know some of the stuff even if you agree
as i do that you know like the
ukrainians
deserve freedom and so on i don't think
that some of the stuff where it's like
being very casual about nuclear war is
smart
and i also think that the fact that
they're still poking on things like
taiwan and so on while they're in the
middle of the russia ukrainian war you
know there's very statements of being
put out on taiwan i think biden put out
some statement and pulled it back and
put out some statement this does not
show a degree of caution on this topic
my point is
i think while american anarchy is
happening or before it gets underway
chinese
control could follow a chinese crackdown
and what does that happen
what does that mean it means chinese
people can't leave the country
it's already happening where passport
issuance is like down 95 over there
they're using the qr codes that they set
up for
the you know coveted stuff for internal
lockdowns
there's already the pre-existing kukau
system of internal passports they know
that lots of hong kong people want to
leave
but they don't want people to leave with
their money
and a lot of chinese people now want to
leave with their money it's called run
zoo r-u-n-x-u-e okay or run philosophy
it's like basically there's three
responses you know for the upper middle
class middle class chinese liberal and
those are rat race life flat
get out or run zoo okay
so
ronzo
will the problem is there's reactivity
on everything and the more popular that
becomes the more it's going to be
portrayed as some combination
unpatriotic some combination you know
like trying to take your money and leave
after all china is done so they're
cutting off the exits in their own way
to your point right so chinese control
is on their side of the world and you
know what they're going to say is
they're going to say look
we just stopped
this american-style anarchy and they're
going to export that surveillance state
to lots of countries and they'll say
look this is just total stability
and you will never have anarchy and you
will just be able to rule forever
because our aii will pick up every
possible form of organization against
you any possible form of dissent
and that's just total order without any
feedback signal whatsoever on power okay
whereas anarchy is the total opposite of
that right so you're going to get i feel
this world that i'm seeing things
tracking towards that where you have
just total disorder over here which will
be justified by saying it's not the
chinese all-seeing eye and you'll have
the chinese all-seeing eye justified by
the fact that it's not the total
disorder here and it's like the nazism
versus communism thing except it is
total decentralization versus total
centralization and the alternative to
that is
many different examples of
recentralization
and what i mean by that is you know you
said pick el salvador pick another
country
the thing is that if you didn't like gem
and you didn't like ford and you didn't
like chrysler well you could found tesla
you could found something that actually
i mean it's very hard you have to be
alone maybe but it was possible to do so
and if it's software if you don't like
you know some
software company you know like you
didn't like google docs people could
found notion right even a big company
you could tackle like this yep so the
thing is that that ability to start that
startup society
even if it doesn't have the full
diplomatic recognition of a network
state
is how those options actually increase
because you mentioned oh if you don't
like the current options go to el
salvador but el salvador is fine
i'm just too close
no i didn't say that and i'm fine with
el salvador i don't have personal issues
with el salvador i'm just saying that
most of the experiments we're talking
about what i mean is of the menu yeah
the menu i'm just like it seems like the
crypto tail is wagging the dog a bit in
the same
way that the tax tail wags the dog when
people are like yeah it's great in this
place and i'm looking at them
in zoom and there are like tires on fire
in the street behind them with razor
wire around their compound and i'm just
like what the [ __ ] are you doing man
like to save whatever you're saving
anyway that's all i'm saying yeah yes no
so that's the thing is also one of the
big things about what i'm talking about
here is it's absolutely morality first
and money second
you know that's saying missionary over
mercenary
so there's this great interview from
several years ago
charlie rose
had an interview
with this historian called paul johnson
okay he essentially points out that the
for-profit colonies in america mostly
failed but as the religious ones that
the cohesion and commitment to make it
through the brutal winters
okay
just like the religious maximalist
community has the cohesion and
commitment to make it through the brutal
crypto winters right
yeah bring it back around to where we're
talking about earlier and just like the
situation that we're potentially
entering in the u.s
it could be
like the next great depression it could
be the great stagnation or the great
stag inflation or the great inflation it
could be not something that bounces back
in a year or two years like our previous
experience but something where the
government cannot print money and cannot
fix it and it has to actually be fixed
with like genuine innovation and not
top-down control and silencing of all
descent and not anarchy and shooting
people but actually innovation that is
that could be by the way very
non-consensus the reason by the way i
bring up something like carb free right
or or sugar free rather
is
if you think about great startups
some of them are very ambitious sounding
like spacex and others sound incredibly
stupid and trivial like 140 characters
right but now today both twitter and
spacex are big companies
and a lot of startup societies will be
similar they'll either sound totally
trivial like carb-free
or insanely ambitious like
fda-free
right and
the thing is you don't necessarily know
which start-up societies are going to
work
you just have to run the experiment and
allow people to set them up society as a
service and allow people to opt into
them and that's what a lot of this book
is about
you